dans cette période de chaos à chaque
jour sa mauvaise nouvelle ou son
scandale
et quand ce n'est pas un problème de
virus mutants ou de masques peu efficace
c'est un soucis liés au vaccin
c'est le journal libération qui fait la
lumière sur un scandale qui pourrait
faire beaucoup de bruit dans les
prochains jours alors que les flacons
duval s'est livré dans le monde par les
laboratoires pfizer était censé contenir
cinq doses de ce précieux élixir
certains se sont rendu compte qu'ils en
contenaient en fait une sixième le
laboratoire assure qu'il est possible
d'en extraire 6 2 mais ce qui aurait pu
être une bonne nouvelle s'avère
aujourd'hui devenir un piège car les
laboratoires pfizer profiterait de cette
information pour réduire les livraisons
de flacons de vaccin en europe
en effet le contrat signé avec l'europe
est calculé sur le nombre de doses
livrées et non sur le nombre de flacons
sauf que certains expliquent qu'en
pratique 7/6 2 n'existe pas toujours où
est parfois difficile voire impossible à
extraire alors vaccins et la sphère de
la 6ème dose un grand scandale ce soir
jimmy mohamed et jean paul hamon sont
avec nous pour nous éclairer sur cette
affaire nous éclairer sur cette affaire
un aura d'autres infos sur le possible
confinement on a eu d'autres rumeurs
qu'on va vous donner dans un instant et
d'ailleurs il ya ce livre aussi qui veut
la peau de nos généralistes que je veux
offrir à mon père bien entendu merci mon
coeur jean paul hamon daniel rosenberg
comment ils tuent la médecine de
proximité et c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que c'est ce que me dit également mon
papa voilà et c'est votre livre merci
d'être là jean paul hamon merci d'être
là mon jimmy d'amour ça va bien merci
d'être là tous les deux alors qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire pour nos
téléspectateurs
cette histoire de 6e doses de vaccins
qui veut qu'ils en parlent en premier
aux gens c'est plutôt très simple en
gros files lorsqu'ils ont livré les deux
avec les flacons on peut faire dans
chaque flacon sac vaccin peut prendre
cinq doses mais l'on s'est rendu compte
dans certains pays en israël en italie
en allemagne qu'on arrive à extraire un
peu plus de doses pour en créer une
sixième
du coup en france on s'est dit bon bah
on va faire aussi la même chose ça
permet d'augmenter de 20% nos capacités
de vaccination
c'est intéressant puisque zurich dose
donc mais les coups c'était pas le
problème surtout vacciner plus puisque
on manque de doses derrière pour être en
conformité on a demandé à l' agence du
médicament européens de dire bon bah
rendez sa officiel non pas que ce soit
de l'arrangement s'il ya des problèmes
on va dire qu'il a vraiment si d'autres
l' agence du médicament dit ok mais
effectivement on va admettre qu'il ya 6
2 et va derrière le laboratoire pfizer
dit ah bah finalement reconnaît
officiellement qu'il ya 6 2
on va donc baisser de
1 % vos dotation qu'on va pouvoir
revendre ailleurs et ça ralentit la
machine néanmoins il faut le rappeler on
court après ces 20 % car on est mauvais
et on n'a pas su s'équiper correctement
si nous avions suffisamment de doses on
se poserait pas la question de ses 20%
si on prend d'autres pays comme israël
qu'avec ces deux millions de personnes
désormais ils vont à partir de demain
commencer à vacciner les enfants de plus
de 16 ans les écoliers lycéens pour
espérer retrouver une vie normale
donc c'est vrai qu'on c# là dessus mais
ça pose un vrai problème 1 un peu
d'éthique c'est un peu des charognards
quand il faut dire la vérité
et puis deuxièmement c'est que c'est pas
si simple d'extra 7/6 dose c'est pas
systématique 1 il faut une aiguille
spéciale qui pour l'instant n'est pas
disponible partout
le gouvernement assure que nous allons
la voir pour tout le monde ici ce
week-end et puis parfois on peut rater
donc on va perdre des doses
donc ça pose quand même un réel problème
dans ce contexte on est un peu dans une
urgence sanitaire et jean paul hamon
président de la fédération des médecins
de france
si vous avez quelque chose à ajouter sur
ce président d'honneur non sauf que sauf
que pour faire les six dose c'est
souvent acrobatique et dans le centre où
j'étais il faut vraiment faire de
prendre des précautions au point qu'on a
laissé deux infirmières pour préparer
leur dose pour pas leur mettre trop de
pression pour qu'elle obtienne cécile
aux elles n'ont pas réussi à tous les
coups et donc la fighter qui vraiment a
du mal à fournir ces doses s'honorerait
en restant sur les cinq doses parce que
figurez vous que ça va faire quand même
près de vingt mille flacons en moins de
livres et donc ça ça c'est un pur
scandale construit c'est vrai qu'on en a
pas c'est déjà des vaccins
on n'a pas assez parce que parce que ben
il est fourni ce salon mais il faut
reconnaître qu'ils ont mis moins d'un an
pour faire un vaccin contre un virus qui
a juste un peu plus d'un an donc ça
c'est un exploit surprise a répété qu'il
est il est génial ça on pouvait pas on
pouvait pas espérer avoir un vaccin en
si peu de temps seulement là ce serait
bien que hi sonore en faisant par les
petits commerçants pour essayer de
grappiller 20 % et 20 % sur ce qu'ils
ont déjà perçu c'est une somme colossale
et non c'est une somme colossale
c'est quoi c'est de l'ordre de quoi ah
là là c'est plusieurs milliers c'est
bien c'est plusieurs milliards et là sur
un coup comme ça et qu'ils peuvent y
présente plusieurs milliards
le secrétaire d'état français aux
affaires européennes clément boon a
demandé à pfizer de livrer en nombre de
flacons et pas en nombre de doses et
leur demande de rectifier le tire donc
peut-être qu'on sera entendue mais quand
même ça prouve qu'on est dépendant de
ses laboratoires et que finalement on
n'est pas grand chose donc ça donne
quand même un message de faiblesse
dans ce contexte on a besoin de montrer
à la population qu'on y va à qu'on va
gagner le combat contre ce virus car
l'objectif l armée mais juste l'agent
jean paul et jimmy la la le gouvernement
il peut pas intervenir là dessus on a
l'impression et je pense que c'est
l'impression que l'on est et
téléspectateurs que les les laboratoires
ont tous les pouvoirs ils font ce qu'ils
veulent alors ils disent eh bah tiens on
va 46e dose on va créer oui il faut
alors on a l'impression et c'est ce que
si c'est ce qui se dit sur les réseaux
c'est ce qui se dit partout voilà
trivialement que ils se foutent de notre
gueule qui pensent qu à l'oseille qui
veulent s'en mettre plein les fouilles
que personne ne les contrôle et que on
va brûler et qu'ont ils n'ouvriront pas
reconduit les gones est l'étape dindon
de la farce
il perd pas ils perdent pas une occase
de smet 20% plus dans les fouilles un ca
croyait et la réalisons quand même
quelques juristes ont analysé les
contrats et qui ont vu que le contrat
qui a été signé mais visiblement il a
été signé en dose il n'a pas été signé
en flacon donc là c'est l'occasion de se
mettre un pour cent de plus dans la
broye des fautes larnack mais ça veut
dire qu'ils ont fait signe à rentrer à
la france un contrat en 12 et non pas un
flacon
c'est comme si vous avez une bouteille
de coca vous dites on va pas vous livrer
en bouteille de coca c'est comme si
comme dans les bars de pression des
bouteilles en plastique de coca pour
dire voilà ça m'a donc ça va nous
rapporter plus d'argent que si on met
des canettes c'est c'est énorme et c'est
incroyable à l'échelle l'échelle des
assises nationales
c'est fou c'est jimmy relais j'ai pu
lire çà qu'a pu dire attendez les mecs
qu'on est en train de se faire enfumer
une agence européenne fait de réfléchir
avant de dévaliser les sea dogs c'est
incroyable dit mais surtout on attend
les autres vaccins
la seule réalité c'est que pour
l'instant on n'a pas de stratégie
vaccinale en a une stratégie de gestion
des stocks bas et comme on a fait
beaucoup de stock est bon nous dit on va
vous vacciner tranquillement jusqu'à
l'été jusqu'à l'automne va falloir vivre
avec une quand on regarde ce qui se
passe du côté des états unis le bilan
est catastrophique chez eux mais
néanmoins ils ont un plan simple avec
l'arrivée de joe biden c'est de vacciner
100 millions d'américains mensonge jour
un million de personnes par jour on
pourrait le faire nous a accéléré la
cadence mais encore une fois on manque
de vaccins ou sacs en cette période
c'est un peu frustrant puisque
finalement on n'avait pas dit que les
français n'avaient pas confiance à la
vaccination est en train de se rendre
compte que ce pas du tout le cas
en vue de se faire vacciner il ya des
complotistes et 10% on va parler que
d'eux mais l'immense majorité des gens
finalement des personnes fragiles celles
qu'on voudrait isolé confiné et bien
envie de se faire vacciner donc un
véritable engouement et à mesure qu'on
va se rendre compte que des pays vont
sortir de la zone rouge
eh bien nous aussi on va vouloir faire
de même sauf qu'entre temps il va
s'écouler plusieurs mois et donc
peut-être encore un de confinement ceux
des morts parce que vous comprenez aussi
est-ce que comprenait que quand on voit
des affaires comme ça les
téléspectateurs et les français se
disent ils sont capables de tout pour
gagner encore plus d'argent pour est ce
qu'on peut avoir vraiment confiance en
ce vaccin parce que ils l'ont fait
tellement rapidement qu'on peut se dire
aussi
ils veulent tout faire pour prix pour
que économiquement il s'en mettre plein
les fouilles et s qui sait ce que c'est
vraiment est ce qu'ils sont vraiment sûr
c'est maxwell n'aura bien sûr ça on peut
avoir confiance et c'est pour ça que moi
qui ai fait le vide il ya neuf mois je
me suivant à câliner justement pour pour
montrer l'exemple
vous êtes fait vacciner tout va bien
tout va bien tout comme airbus a pas
beaucoup mais non mais c'est vrai que là
l'industrie pharmaceutique et l'agro la
gros à perdre dans cette affaire donc
ils n'ont pas à prendre le moindre
risque sur le plan sur le plan sanitaire
mais là sur un coup comme ça essayer de
grappiller enfin pas grappiller mais de
se faire 20 % plus un nombre assez un
pur ce que vous êtes fait vacciner du
mit je veux un parti encore des
catégories à risque j'avais 50 ans mais
j'ai envie de le faire pour le faire
mais j'ai participé à la vaccination et
les gens étaient contents
j'ai vacciner des personnes âgées qui
venaient en couple certains qui me
disent écoutez ça fait neuf mois on est
confiné
on n'en peut plus et donc c'est un peu
la délivrance donc on a hâte que ça
arrive et on se rend pas bien compte de
la chance qu'on a c'est une révolution
saxe est donc vivement qu'on puisse
enfin avoir ces doses pour vacciner
massivement c'est qu'on entend tout le
monde parlait de confinement j'ai
entendu aujourd'hui
bien sûr tout ça à prendre au
conditionnel et cheick parce qu'on a
tous entendu des rumeurs
il paraîtrait que le 28 ce serait
annoncée pour un roe confinement le 30
janvier
est-ce que vous avez les mêmes infos il
ya plusieurs scénarios sur la table pour
l'instant alors la seule question c'est
plus de savoir est-ce qu'on va confiné
sait quand et comment donc je suis à
dire les choses telles qu'elles ont
toutes façons on va être confiné il faut
laisser la seule façon de s'en sortir
la question c'est ce qu'on va attendre
encore une fois que le système soit
débordé ce qu'il faut souffrir pour être
confiné la question là où est ce qu'on
va voir un peu d'avancé puisque on a
l'impression que les médecins veulent
confiner vous croyez vous croyez moi ça
fait pas plaisir d'être confiné mois
soul autant que vous le court d'avril
j'en ai ras-le-bol et j'ai envie qu'on
passe à autre chose mais il faut bien
comprendre que plus tôt aux consignes
plus tôt on va sortir plus tôt on va
casser l'épidémie et chaque jour cinq
semaines de perdues
eh bien ça va se payer en confinement
qui va durer plus longtemps alors il ya
eu cette histoire de confinement qui va
peut-être débuté le week-end simplement
peut-être qu'on va avancer les vacances
scolaires qui va y avoir des vacances
pour tout le monde à partir du 6 février
quelles que soient les deux voiles
orezone et puis à quelque chose qu'on
peut proposer peut-être que le
gouvernement écoute mais ce qu'on
pourrait faire c'est de mettre tout le
monde en vacances pendant six à à partir
du 6 février donnait deux semaines de
vacances you never say des chroniqueurs
et rattraper les deux semaines de
vacances perdu au moment de juillet et
deux semaines supplémentaires pour une
scolarité et enfin vous avez pause
pendant un mois
lorsque je peux faire noté jean-paul la
bonne nouvelle la bonne nouvelle quand
même c'est que nous les français
adhèrent massivement à la vaccination
est rarement au sondage qu'on avait et
même les 10% de complotiste ils seront
protégés parce qu'autour il y aura des
gens à vacciner certainement ils vont
pas mettre tout de suite c'est ça qui
est dommage quoi donc
donc voila et donc vous avez entendu
parler au sirop confinement de finale je
sais pas on est on est quand même sur un
plateau élevé de depuis depuis deux mois
ça ça bouge pas où ça grimpe doucement
je pense qu'on pourrait effectivement
fermer carrément les frontières avec
l'angleterre avec le royaume uni en en
permettant aux gens de ne rentrer sur le
sur le territoire qu'avec une vraie pcr
négative
un confinement de sept jours et il
aurait le droit de sortir s'il y avait
une pcr négative à la sortie il faut
limiter l'arrivée du du des variants
andré sur le territoire ou s'il est déjà
présent mais chaque jour qu'on gagne
c'est déjà ça de pris et c'est pour ça
que moi je trouve que c'est léger enfin
imposé penser au confinement déjà alors
qu'on est sur un plat sur un plateau je
trouve que ce serait dommage de ne pas
continuer parce que les vacances
arrivent tous les experts les
épidémiologistes et il ya une pression
un petit peu visible pour le
gouvernement le conseil scientifique qui
doivent en toutes lettres de d'accélérer
le confinement et puis à des arguments
économiques et effectuant c'est ça qu'on
attend encore mais ça risque de se payer
encore plus la seule chose on parle du
variant anglais il est présent sur le
territoire de toute façon et on nous a
dit que cette semaine il serait présent
à hauteur de 1,4 pour cent des pcr
positive 1,4 quand je vous dis ça ça
fait pas peur
le khat ont dit c'est peu je vais si la
semaine prochaine on est à 3 %
c'est le début de l'expo n'en ciel c'est
la perte de contrôle du virus lorsqu'on
parle du plateau à 20000 contamination
par jour mon impression 20000 sais rien
or le président avait dit qu'il fallait
5001 combinations marjo pour tester
tracé et isoler correctement ça veut
dire qu'on a perdu le contrôle du virus
etc à mesure qu'on laisse le temps passé
et bien le variant anglais il va se
propager va prendre le dessus sur
l'autre
coronado truc en ce moment il ya deux
épidémies l'épidémie de coronavirus
classique et le variant anglais qui
prend effectivement un peu de chemin qui
peut à son gré
la perspective du sud africain alors là
avec chaque problème à la fois mais
effectivement il est très inquiétant
puisque on se rend compte que peut-être
il échapperait au vaccin il ya
l'immunité conférée par la maladie donc
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge si on se
vaccine pas rapidement il a raison à
mesures de contrôle aux frontières c'est
pas être nationaliste s'est pas être
bien sûr xénophobe c'est de se dire en
cette période dont la sauce faut axer ai
posé la question du passeport vaccinale
dans quelques temps est ce qu'on aura
droit de venir en france si on n'est pas
vaccinée non maintenant ce qu'il faut
dire non il faut qu'on ait le courage de
poser le débat et pas attendre on dit
qu'il sait pas le moment d'en discuter
je pense qu'il faut rapidement dire oui
ou non
mettons à passeport vaccinale pour enfin
sortir de la galère